Film Courage: In terms of finding a person
of influence that you want to have look at
your work or get in contact with, I think
there is a fine line in Los Angeles with so
many people being pitched.
How aggressive do you get?
Because you don’t want to turn someone off.
Marc Scott Zicree: Well, one person (a writer)
was once asked “When do you take no for
an answer.”
And he said “When they call security!”
But I don’t really subscribe to that.
The real answer is first of all treat people
the way you would want to be treated, so don’t
be a jerk.
I mean for one thing, you have no idea how
many people in various circumstances will
jam me up against a wall and start pitching
their story to me.
It’s like “Mr. Zicree!
Mr. Zicree!
You have to hear this.
Okay, okay FADE IN…we open on the sky and
we see the clouds and we’re panning down,
we’re panning down.
We see birds and we’re panning down, we’re
panning down.
We see a spire and it’s the Empire State
Building.
And we’re down it, a hundred and second,
hundred and first!”
Gosh!
You know…please…no!
First of all, when you are pitching, never
pitch every beat, every shot.
No!
It’s the broad strokes.
But also you shouldn’t be pitching.
Is that person buying stories?
Why are you pitching to them?
What’s in it for them?
But also, no one likes to be pitched in a
social circumstance or if they’re giving
a talk.
It’s like [sighs] do I really want to stand
here and listen for 20 minutes to someone’s
story that I’ve known from the first minute
is awful!
No.
What you want to do is first of all if you
go to an event and someone who you admire
is speaking, you remember The Rule of Three.
The Rule of Three is most people make the
mistake of immediately pitching or immediately
“I’m an actor.
You’ve got to cast me.
Here’s my headshot.
Here is my reel.”
You don’t know, you have not established
a relationship with that person.
The first time you meet them at an event,
you just say something truthful (maybe about
their work) but it has to be specific.
“You know, there was that scene in that
movie you did in 1981 where the little boy
was talking to his mother.
I had this really difficult relationships
with my mother.
When I saw that scene it opened a door in
me somehow and I went and had a conversation
with my mom and it changed our relationship.”
That’s something that is going to resonate.
That’s something truthful and meaningful
from your heart.
But don’t gush and don’t go on at length,
okay?
Because there are going to be other people
who want to talk to this guy.
The other part, so the you go to a second
event with that person and if you have a chance
to talk to them at the end “Oh, hi!
Mr. so-and-so.
You know last time when we spoke and I told
you about my mom and you said such and such,
it really meant so much to me that you really
care.”
Or you say something again “And I just really
want to let you know how much that meant to
me,” right?
Then you go to the third event.
The third event you run into them you say
“Oh gosh, we keep running into each other.
It’s like we’re swimming in the same aquarium.
And it’s like, you’ve been so kind talking
to me these last two times and there is something
you said last time we talked.
I really applied it.
I made this film (or blah-blah-blah, whatever).”
“Also I read in The Trades that you’re
looking for a Western and basically the conversation
I’m having I just thought, I don’t know
if you’d be open to it?
But I’ve written a Western and I’d love
to have my representation send it to you,
if you’d be open to that?”
Or whatever the request is, you say it in
a very respectful manner.
You don’t go on at length.
You stop at “Yes” or if he says no “That’s
fine.”
You let is go.
But the point is by then you’re not jerk
because you didn’t push the button at the
first moment and secondly he’s gotten enough
about you where he’s intrigued about you,
so that’s the way you do it (or that’s
one way to do it).
Another way to do it is if you go to any event…(Continue
to Part 2).